أعتقد أنه لا يوجد شك في أن هناك
قلقًا عندما تنظر إلى ما
يحدث مع هذه الاحتجاجات من
وجهة نظر فيروس كورونا ، من الواضح أن هذه
الاحتجاجات ذات مغزى ومهمة للغاية ،
لكن فكرة أن الفيروس قد
تغير بطريقة ما ، وهذا ليس هو
الحال ، لا يزال الفيروس موجودًا.
لا يزال معديًا جدًا ، لذا عندما تنظر
إلى هذه الصور ، هناك عدة أشياء يجب أن تضعها في
اعتبارك أن الكثير من الأشخاص يرتدون أقنعة
وهذا أمر جيد
نعلم أن الأقنعة يمكن أن يكون لها تأثير كبير
على انتشار الفيروس ، تكون هذه
الاحتجاجات في الغالب في الخارج ، وهذا أمر
جيد أيضًا لأن  سوف
ينتشر الفيروس أكثر في الهواء ولكن
من الواضح أن الأشخاص على مقربة منهم
لا يبتعدون جسديًا في بعض
هذه الصور ويبقون في
هذه المواضع لمدة تزيد عن 10 أو 15
دقيقة ، لذلك لديك العديد من المواقف
التي يكون لديك فيها اتصال وثيق  وإذا
تم تشخيص الأشخاص
بعد ذلك بالعدوى لي ، فسؤال
كيف يمكنك العودة وتتبع جميع
جهات الاتصال الخاصة بالأشخاص في  في منتصف
الاحتجاج ، من الصعب جدًا القيام بذلك ، ونتيجة لذلك
قد نواجه صعوبة في معرفة
مدى تأثير هذه الاحتجاجات
بشكل عام على عدوى فيروس كورونا الجديد.
تحدث اثنتان من هذه القوى
في نفس الوقت مما سيجعلها
تتحدى المتظاهرين فعليهم بذل
قصارى جهدهم بشكل واضح لمحاولة كبح
انتشار هذا الفيروس والتفكير أيضًا
بعد عودتهم إلى المنزل ، ما الذي يمكنهم
فعله إذا لم ينتشروا
الفيروس للأشخاص داخل أسرهم
داخل مجتمعهم ، سيكون كل
هذا نوعًا ما مهمًا للغاية خلال
الأسابيع العديدة القادمة ، وقد لا نعرف
تأثير ذلك لبضعة أسابيع أيضًا
لأنه بين
وقت التعرض لوقت إجراء الاختبار  قد يستغرق وقت
ظهور أي أعراض للأشخاص الذين
تظهر عليهم الأعراض عدة
أسابيع ، لذا سنراقب ذلك ، وأريد أيضًا
أن أريكم بسرعة هذه
الخريطة لما يحدث هنا في  الولايات
المتحدة أسبوعًا إلى أسبوع ، تحصل على فكرة عن
الأماكن التي يتزايد فيها عدد المرضى الجدد المصابين
بفيروس كورونا
حيث يتناقص ، وإذا كنت
تنظر إلى هذه الخرائط ، فأنت تعلم أنها
تتغير قليلاً وليس فقط من أسبوع لآخر
ولكن حتى  يومًا بعد يوم ، انظر أيضًا
إلى الرسم البياني لحالات فيروس كورونا
الجديدة ويمكنك أن ترى هنا الحصول على فكرة
عن خط الاتجاه العام ، فهناك بعض
الحالات التي كان لديك فيها أكبر
عدد من الإصابات الجديدة التي تم الإبلاغ عنها جزءًا
من ذلك بسبب الزيادة  الاختبار
ولكن جزءًا من ذلك لأن هذا الفيروس
يستمر في الانتشار ، حيث تقوم الدول بإعادة فتح
الناس يقومون بعمل جيد إلى حد معقول
في العديد من الأماكن لمحاولة الحفاظ على
تلك المسافة المادية لمحاولة ارتداء
الأقنعة ، ونأمل أن يساعد ذلك
وسيحدد الوقت
فقط مقدار  تأثير نظرًا لأننا نحصل على مزيد من
المعلومات حول كل هذا
سيحققه لك
بالتأكيد وسأرى الجميع غدًا ، من فضلك
دعنا نذهب إلى المنزل.
الأشخاص الذين احتجوا خلال
الأسبوعين الماضيين هم  يُنصح بإجراء اختبار
لـ kovat 19 ، أعتقد أن هناك
احتمالًا لسوء الحظ أن يكون هذا
حدث جلوس د.  يقول روبرت ريدفيلد ،
مدير مراكز السيطرة على
الأمراض والوقاية منها ، إن خطر
الإصابة بالعدوى أكثر احتمالًا في
المدن الكبرى التي تم السيطرة على
تفشيها ، ويصادف أن تكون مينيابوليس
لا تزال تعاني من
انتقال كبير للناقلات المباشرة ، وأخرى نريد حقًا أن يتم أخذ
هؤلاء الأفراد
بعين الاعتبار.  على الرغم من أن بعض
المتظاهرين يرتدون أقنعة ، إلا أن هناك حدًا أدنى من
التباعد الاجتماعي بين الحشود ، ويمكن
للغاز المسيل للدموع الذي تستخدمه أحيانًا جهات
إنفاذ القانون أن يجعل الناس يسعلون
ويزيد من احتمالية انتشار
الفيروس الذي دافعنا عنه بقوة عن
القدرة على تغطية الوجه بأقنعة
متاحة للمتظاهرين بحيث  يمكنهم
على الأقل الحصول على تلك الأغطية التي نشرها مركز السيطرة على الأمراض
يوم الخميس والتي
تتنبأ بأكثر من 127 ألف حالة وفاة
في الولايات المتحدة  بحلول السابع والعشرين من يونيو ، قال الباحثون
إن البيانات تشير إلى انخفاض
الوفيات الأسبوعية بسبب فيروس كورونا ، لكن ذلك قد يتغير
إذا انتشر فيروس كورونا بين
المحتجين ، أنا جون لورانس
أبلغكم بأن
نيوزيلندا أبلغت عن عدم وجود
حالات إصابة بفيروس كورونا في الدولة بأكملها
لأول مرة منذ أواخر فبراير.
تمت الإشادة بالبلاد على
إجراءاتها المبكرة وإجراءاتها الصارمة
لمحاربة الفيروس في الساعة
الماضية ، أعلن نسل رئيس الوزراء إدورن
تخفيف جميع القيود المحلية التي ألغتها
كريستي من CNN
وتنضم إلينا الآن من هونج كونج للحديث أكثر
عنها نعم نيوزيلندا عالية  يشير إلى
كيفية تعامله مع الفيروس
ويبدو أن هذه الإجراءات قد آتت ثمارها تمامًا ،
هذه لحظة مهمة
للاحتفال بخمسة ملايين
شخص اتصلوا بمنزل نيوزيلندا
حيث أبلغت عن 0 حالات إصابة بفيروس كورونا في المرة الأولى منذ وصول kovin 19 لأول مرة
في نيوزيلندا في الثامن والعشرين من فبراير ، يأتي هذا
أيضًا بعد 17 يومًا متتاليًا من عدم وجود
إصابات جديدة محلية وكذلك ar
أعلنت الحكومة النيوزيلندية والحكومة
أنها تخفف قيودها المتعلقة بالوباء
إلى مستوى تنبيه واحد اعتبارًا من منتصف الليل ،
وسمعنا من رئيس الوزراء
جاستن داردن في مؤتمر صحفي
خلال الساعة الماضية ، إليكم ما قالت
إن النيوزيلنديين فعلوا شيئًا
رائعًا في معركتنا  يجب تغطيتنا 19
نحن متحدون بطرق غير مسبوقة
لسحق الفيروس ، كان إغلاقنا ساري المفعول بعد 26
يومًا من حالتنا الأولى اليوم ، لا
توجد حالات نشطة في نيوزيلندا ،
قمنا باختبار ما يقرب من 40 ألف شخص
لأكثر من 19 في الأيام الـ 17 الماضية ولم يحدث أي
منها  كانت نتيجة الاختبار إيجابية ، لم نقرأ أي شخص في
المستشفى مقابل 19 مشفرًا لمدة 12 يومًا ، لقد
مرت 40 يومًا منذ آخر حالة
انتقال مجتمعي 22 يومًا منذ
أن انتهى هذا الشخص من
عزله الذاتي ، ولذا يمكنني اليوم أن أعلن
أن مجلس الوزراء قد وافق على الانتقال الآن
إلى  المستوى 1 لفتح اقتصادنا بالكامل
مرة أخرى كان رئيس الوزراء جاستن آر
ديرن يتحدث أنهم يعلنون أن
بلادها ستنتقل إلى مستوى تنبيه واحد.
تبدأ من منتصف الليل الليلة ،
فماذا يعني ذلك يعني
أن نهاية التباعد الاجتماعي القسري
في الدولة مما يعني أن أماكن العمل
ستعيد فتح المدارس سابقًا ،
كان هناك حظر على التجمعات الاجتماعية
لأكثر من 100 شخص
لم يعد حظر نيوزيلندا موجودًا  مكان ولكن على الرغم
من نهاية المبادئ التوجيهية الصارمة للتباعد الاجتماعي ،
إلا أنها ستظل تمنع
المسافرين الدوليين الأجانب من
دخول البلاد في الواقع خلال
المؤتمر الصحفي قالت جاسينتا أردن
إن السبب في ذلك هو الضوابط الصارمة على
الحدود وهذا هو السبب الذي يجعل
الحكومة تفكر في ذلك.  تخفيف
هذه القيود الوبائية ، ولكن
هناك بعض الإعفاءات
لبعض المسافرين الدوليين في الخارج
الذين يمكنهم إثبات قدرتهم على
الاستفادة من الاقتصاد في نيوزيلندا ،
وقد أكدت CNN للتو أن
مخرج أفلام هوليوود جيمس
كاميرون وطاقمه حصلوا على
إذن من New New Zealand  حكومة نيوزيلندا
لدخول البلاد للعمل على
تتمة للفيلم الرمزية في محاولة
للمساعدة في إعادة تشغيل الاقتصاد إليك